très pas d'état d'âme en tout cas pour
les américains le nouvel eldorado
s'appelle internet bill clinton en
personne n'hésite pas à le dire
franchement internet sera bien le
nouveau pari est le nouveau défi des
états unis les explications de jean
jacques peyraud on peut déjà sur
l'internet acheter des livres des
disques des vêtements des logiciels sans
sortir de chez soi
ce mode d'achat pourrait représenter
dans cinq ans de 5 à 15 % du commerce de
détail le rapport approuvé hier par bill
clinton veut encore accélérer le
mouvement
il décide d'abandonner toute idée de
taxe et toute forme de contrôle de
l'état américain sur le commerce
électronique l'internet de fait devient
une zone franche virtuel de dimension
planétaire les autres états en europe
surtout prêche pour un contrôle douanier
du commerce électronique ils veulent
prélever des taxes mais il leur sera
difficile de l'imposer pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que si compliqué à mettre
en place
et deuxièmement parce que la loi dit
plus nombreux va s'imposer car
n'oublions pas que deux internautes sur
trois sont américains le village global
pour l'essentiel il est américain et il
adoptera le modèle clinton qui consiste
à dire laissons l'internet s'organise
lui même les états ne doivent pas s'en
mêler
ajoutons que ce sera vrai aussi en
matière de contrôle du contenu le fameux
decency acte américains qui prétendaient
censurer les messages licencieux a été
annulée avant-hier par la cour suprême
au nom de la libre expression et des
pays comme l'allemagne engagée dans une
politique de filtrage vont se trouver
isolées
les etats-unis jouent sur du velours en
s'érigeant en défenseur de la liberté de
parole et de les changes et du coup ils
vont se tailler la part du lion dans le
commerce électronique mondial
et puis